>> Stephen: WELCOME BACK,
EVERYBODY.
BEFORE THE COMMERCIAL BREAK, I
WAS GRILLING OHIO CONGRESSWOMAN
MARSHA FUDGE, WHICH IF YOU ADD
MARSHMALLOW AND GRAHAM CRACKERS
WOULD MAKE A CONGRESSIONAL
S'MORE.
>> MUSIC TRANSCENDS EVERYTHING
UNTIL WE DECIDED IT'S GOING TO
BE A GREAT IDEA TO HAVE
MUSICIANS COME TOGETHER.
>> Stephen: IS IT FAIR TO SAY
YOU WANT TO ROCK US OUT WITH OUR
CAUCUS OUT?
>> YES
>> Stephen: WOULD YOU BE
WILLING TO SAY THAT?
>> UH, ROCK US OUT WITH OUR
CAUCUS OUT
>> Stephen: EXCELLENT. THERE'S A
LOT OF AFFECTION FOR YOU RIGHT
NOW FOR REASONS I CAN'T EXPLAIN
(APPLAUSE)
DO YOU HAVE A PAC?
>> I DO.
AND IS IT CALLED FUDGE PAC?
IT IS NOT?
>> NO.
>> Stephen: THINK IT'D BE A
GOOD NAME, THOUGH?
>> NO.
>> Stephen: EVERYONE WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE A BUMPER STICKER
SAYING "I AM A FUDGE PACKER."
IT WOULD BE GREAT.
YOU THINK ABOUT THAT?
>> I'LL THINK ABOUT IT.
>> Stephen: MOVING ON.
YOU WERE AN OUTSTANDING ATHLETE.
>> I WAS.
>> Stephen: IN YOUR YOUTH.
YOU WERE A FENCING CHAMPION IN
HIGH SCHOOL.
>> YES.
>> Stephen: I'VE DONE A LITTLE
FENCING.
>> HAVE YOU?
>> Stephen: CONGRESSWOMAN...
(LAUGHTER)
I CHALLENGE YOU TO A DUEL.
>> I ACCEPT!
♪♪
>> Stephen: MY NAME IS STEPHEN
COLBERT. YOU DISSED PAUL RYAN.
PREPARE TO DIE.
IF I WIN, YOU MAKE ME A MEMBER
OF THE CONGRESSIONAL BLACK
CAUCUS.
IF YOU WIN, I'LL MAKE YOU A
MEMBER OF THE WHITE CAUCUS.
I'LL TALK TO SOMEBODY.
>> DEAL!
♪♪
>> Stephen: WHOSE IS THAT?
>> MINE.
>> Stephen: WHAT!
♪♪
THAT WAS ME, BABY!
THAT WAS ALL ME!
(APPLAUSE)
SO, THAT'S TWO OUT OF THREE?
>> TWO OUT OF THREE.
♪♪
(APPLAUSE)
>> Stephen: I ACCEPT YOUR
DEFEAT GRACIOUSLY.
I AM NOW A PROUD MEMBER OF THE
CONGRESSIONAL BLACK CAUCUS.
LET'S PUT OHIO'S 11th UP ON
THE BIG BOARD!
OH!
LOOKS LIKE THE CUYAHOGA RIVER IS
HAVING ITS FOURTEENTH FIRE.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.